[Musique]
je m'appelle et j'habite près d'ici je
m'appelle et les îles disent que vous
êtes allergique au monde c'est ça qu'on
dit non je crois qu'on peut dire soir il
a cherché partout un spécialiste qui
pourrait aider
tu vas aller mieux promis
promis
bonjour il y je soumets docteur horn
bonjour j'espère que tu ne vois pas ça
comme une clinique pour moi c'est un
foyer et pour l'instant c'est envoyé ça
fait si longtemps
toutes les choses pour lesquelles j'ai
prié sont ici on commence tout ma vie
qu'est ce qui te rend malade
beaucoup de choses l'air l'eau la
poussière l'état délit va s'aggraver
avant de s'améliorer
il y avait quelque chose dans ma chambre
les cauchemars font partie des effets
secondaires c'est parfaitement normal je
veux pas te faire peur mais cet endroit
ça me fait flipper je crois qu'elles
meurent encore plus malade c'est le
traitement qui fait ses poils traitement
qui fait ça et si ça marche mais
pourquoi je me sens encore plus mal
parce que ça marche
il s'est passé un truc grave ici
absolument pas tout de suite ce que sa
vie est en danger
pourquoi tu fais ça tu es plus malade
que tu ne le crois pas et celle de
m'approcher
je suis pas malade mais sûrement sortir
tu vas aller mieux promis